wo ist dein weg
halle junger mann
wo kommst du denn jetzt her ich war
draußen ich habe meine tasche gefunden
hat die polizei eine tasche gefunden
nein selber auch roh wer ist denn sap
macht niemand kann man mit ich habe eine
tolle überraschung für dich eine
überraschung was das sind sachen von
günter winter war mein mann er lebt
nicht mehr
er hat immer sehr elegante kleidung
getragen alles ist so gut wie neu
zumal dieses schicke hemd und die braune
hose geht ja sicher sehr gut sieht
bequem aus wehrlos probiere die sachen
an
ich finde du bist ein hübscher junger
mann
das steht dir ganz toll sehr elegant ein
gestreiftes hemd und eine warme hose und
ganze getue
naja ich weiß nicht wer ist das denn
hallo hallo ich bin jetzt helmes nikutta